hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well among the
perennial issue is concerned with
friendship or love or relationships the
Aristotle examines in nikka mccann
ethics book 8 is one that is still on a
lot of people's minds today I think
every single generation he has to work
through and work out their own solution
to this oftentimes the solutions end up
looking very much like what would pass
thinkers have come up with like what
aerosol is going to tell us here and
this question is can a person have many
friends I think that this is a
particularly interesting and acute issue
in the present given the proliferation
of social media through the internet and
through mobile technology because
Facebook calls itself a community which
is composed of all these relationships
of friends and we can say that well you
know google+ and linkedin and twitter
they don't do that they have following
or you know connections but it's really
you know the same sort of question about
what's going on with those connections
same thing I suppose
I don't even know what happens with
Instagram because I'm not on that but in
any case it's it's a real live question
even before social media I believe it or
not you know human beings existence that
for most of their history this is still
a major issue can a person have many
friends and had no quarrel it to that
would be well should a person try to
have many friends or should a person
just try him a few friends it is it a
good thing to have more friends than to
have less friends and if we think about
this in an Aristotelian perspective this
is what Aristotle's analysis is so
useful there is an ambiguity involved
here we're not asking about something
that means the same thing in every
situation friend friendship he has a
wide range of meaning it has as they put
your multiple senses so you know Arizona
doesn't just distinguish between these
three types of friendship that I've shot
another video about and actually done
separate videos about each of these he
also talks about mixed or unequal
relationships he also talks about the
family relatives you know all sorts of
other people who we have relationships
with whether we really like it or not
we're sort of you know we come into the
fabric of it whereas these tend to be
voluntary connections that we made and
no that's that even with those we have
three main types that Aristotle's way to
distinguish putting aside the mixture
unequal relationships we have
friendships of virtue based on who the
person is and you can only have this
kind of friendship if you really do have
a virtue to offer and as the other
prison is richer to offer we have
friendships that are based on pleasure
the pleasure that perhaps that people
provide each other or the pleasure that
they take in in associating and enjoying
a common thing and then we have
friendships on utility and Aristotle
will tell us that there's a couple
factors that make it impossible for us
to get
many friends in terms of version first
of all the fact that there aren't a lot
of virtuous people to begin with but it
requires time a lot of time you spend
with that person to against if I don't
whether they are indeed purchase and to
build up that friendship we can have
friends we have many more friends who
are friendships of pleasure because it's
easier to tie into them you want to know
whether its pleasant to spend time with
somebody you don't need to know them for
months on end you can tell fairly
quickly whether you actually enjoy
spending time with them and although
they might lie to you of course they can
they can probably give you some sort of
indication whether they enjoy spending
time with you as well so it's quite
possible to have many friends in terms
of pleasure you could be on a sports
team for example and be friends in that
sense with everybody on the team at
least if you if you like spending time
together the people that you hang out
with can be friendships in terms of
pleasure you know we could you could be
part of a social club there's all sorts
of possibilities that wide into the
scope and I think in terms of social
media because we now live in a virtual
world case in point talking to you right
here right we can widen that even more
so that people who live in areas where
perhaps they couldn't find that many
people that they could enjoy things with
can down abuse some friendships in terms
of utility we can have all sorts of
friends in terms of utility we don't
need to know them very well we're not
particularly interested in their
character except that we don't want them
screw us over or deprive us of whatever
good it is that we want they may not
even be pleasant to be with lots of
people can fit the bill for this and you
don't need any time necessarily to
figure that out you may not even need to
know much about the person other than
their bio to tell whether they're going
to be useful for you and then we need of
course we have the mixed or unequal
relationships the family relationships
that adds other new wrinkles to it you
might have
or family my bus family right but if we
if we're considering whether we can have
many friends or whether it's a good
thing to have many friends as we move
through these the the situation changes
now of course friendships based on
pleasure utility our house lasting as
friendships based on virtue so it could
be that sort of a rotating door thing
you know you think about people with
their romantic or ironic relationships
we talk about people have being serial
monogamous that means that they go from
one relationship where they're in a
committed relationship break breaks up
another relationship breaks out another
relationship obviously in that sense you
can't have that many friendships of
pleasure but at the same time that you
have that you may also have your sports
team humein out of your social club you
may have your circle of friends you may
have all sorts of other things going on
right so it so it is quite possible to
have many more friends the the more
superficial the less personal in the
sense of being about the person's
themselves the relationship turns out to
be and we can represent that graphically
here I'm not a great graphic artist so
of course you're gonna have done you
know see what I'm talking about here we
have certain like a pyramid you might
say and depending on where we locate
ourselves the answer is yes or no we
locate ourselves at the top where virtue
exists that's assuming that we actually
haven't revert you to offer the other
person it's maybe a you know foreclosed
possibility for some people but that's
also why you know mixture unequal
relationships are important could be
that you offer pleasure or usefulness to
the other person who has virtue but you
still can't have a lot of friendships of
virtue because it takes so long yeah
these are relatively rare so you can't
have a lot of friends in the fullest
sense of friendship it's just not
possible from an Aristotelian
perspective as a matter of fact it's not
even desirable because by spreading
yourself out too thin you don't have
enough time at
energy to devote to that one or two or
three very close friends friendship in
terms of pleasure okay we can have more
people involved there we could share it
with a lot wider range of persons
because more people can fit the bill and
it doesn't take as long to develop as a
matter of fact when they quit being
pleasant they'll shuffle off the scene
and we'll find somebody else to to
replace them friendships of utility at
the bottom yes can a person have any
friends absolutely you can have as many
friends as you want and again to talk in
terms of social networks you know
Facebook cuts you off 500 but I actually
do know some people who we have 500
friends on Facebook they whatever they
may think about how they're connected
with these people those are not
friendships with virtue they may in fact
know some of those people outside of
this would probably do may have known
them for a long time but there there's
no way that they're spending you know
enough time with 5,000 people to be
friends a virtue with them probably it's
not even a matter of pleasure in a lot
of cases probably it's just what we
would call usefulness some people get a
kick out of having a lot of friends some
people enjoy working the connections
that's that's less about pleasure more
about utility right yeah so you know why
they're your your range of friends the
more things are happening down in here
is this a good thing or a bad thing
Aristotle doesn't say that there's
anything wrong with this as a matter of
fact the main thing that Aristotle seems
to be concerned about is distinguishing
between these and saying look if you're
going to have very close friends don't
mix them up with these people because
friendships of those sorts don't work
the same way so to answer the question
can any person had many friends well yes
and no it depends on where you fit in
with this and what sense of the term
you're using for currents it may be that
some people don't have any
friends in terms of virtue and it's all
down here and they appear to have lots
and lots and lots of friends talk about
people like that is being popular and
quite often people like that are not
super happy because they don't have this
upper-level thing sometimes people
pretend that people in these classes are
the bffs the best friends forever of
virtue but if you have what it takes to
have that relationship that's not going
to actually last so these are all very
important things to keep in mind